relation to russian aggression and
that's what we're talking about it's
very important that we stand
united with our allies united with nato
it's also important that in the uk our
political parties are united against
russian aggression
but i do want to see the government
going further in relation to sanctions i
don't think they've used the powers that
they've already got
as much as they should have done and i
don't think they've looked closely
enough at their own donations and i
think any donations the conservative
party that have any link
to putin should be looked at very very
carefully and i want to see further
sanctions put in place as quickly as
possible um and you know been waiting
for an economic crime bill for some time
now that needs to happen needs to happen
fast and we'll push the government all
the way on this what sanctions would
labor take if if russia were to invade
ukraine firstly use the powers we've got
we do have powers that are being used as
extensively as they should be in
addition to that absolute transparency
through companies house so we know where
the money is coming from
much greater action on donations to
political parties um and the economic
crime bill brought into law as quickly
as possible with real teeth to these
sanctions